hey 42 here have you ever heard of the
world's deadliest fart no well let me
lead you to Cameroon celebrated for its
coffee cotton and cacao oh and don't
forget his football team the indomitable
Lions who've qualified for the World Cup
nine times a feat unequaled by any other
African team their best performance came
in 1990 when they made it to the
quarterfinals only to be narrowly
defeated by The Three Lions of England
in extra time England progressed to the
semi-finals only to continue its
venerable custom of losing on penalties
but that's the story best left for
another time or more likely than other
channel anyway let's get back to that
fatal fart Cameroon has a population of
25 million people and over 250 native
languages but in scientific circles
their stirs are stories so surreal it
has eternally solidified Cameroon on the
world map on the 21st of August 1986 in
the desolate reaches of Lake NEOS in the
Northwest there was a natural disaster
or more accurately a limnic eruption
this catastrophe claimed the lives of
around 1 800 people and 3500 lifestyle
and even though it was technically a
volcanic eruption it wasn't anything
like the kind you and I know instead of
a spewing torrent of lava and smoke this
eruption materialized as a giant gas
cloud
Lake NEOS is a deep Crater Lake located
high on the side of an inactive volcano
in the Aku volcanic plain and forms part
of a 1600 kilometer chain of volcanoes
known as The Cameroon line
now if someone tried to Peddle you a
property perched on the precipice of a
volcano you'd probably pass it up still
the areas around volcanoes are
fantastically fertile places for farming
and therefore usually densely populated
just after 2 million people who now live
in the vicinity of mad Vesuvius near
Naples because who cares about trifling
Tales such as the destruction of Pompeii
and Herculaneum when you can cultivate
the world's best tomatoes in the rich
volcanic soil and make the most Divine
pizzas known to man anyway you get the
point and sure enough in 1986 the area
around Lake NEOS was home to a large
populace of people farming crops and
cattle the bathmen who have inhabited
the area for centuries were some of the
earliest settlers and as a ruler only
Built their houses on elevated ground
above a lake and never below it a
tradition rooted in local folklore that
describes Lakes doing strain means
things like rising and falling changing
locations or even blowing up
Scholars speculate these beliefs were
born from bygone events and passed down
through the type of oral tradition that
nobody ever records but we really
probably should because if they had
perhaps thousands of lives would have
been saved
you see there was a ticking Time Bomb
about 50 miles beneath the lake in the
form of a silent but deadly magma
chamber gradually the magma released
gases including carbon dioxide which
filled the surrounding Rock before
seeping into the lake itself
this exact process is only known to
occur in a few Lakes worldwide but most
notably Lake kivu in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and Lake manoon
also in Cameroon after traveling through
the rock the gas dissolves into the
water when the Lake's waters are
stratified and don't mix a considerable
buildup of gas on the lower layers
particularly carbon dioxide can occur it
can actually sit stably in the state for
some time but a sudden mixing of the
upper and lower levels results in a
limnic eruption which is like opening a
bottle of champagne or for the more lewd
Learners out there it's like farting in
the bath
this is precisely what happened at Lake
NEOS however rewind to several weeks
before this calamitous combustion and
the chilling side greeted the locals one
morning all the fish in the lake had
perished overnight their lifeless bodies
were found drifting on the surface
it transpired that the carbon dioxide
levels had attained a fatal
concentration in the Lake's depths as
phyxiating nearly all living creatures
within then a few weeks later came the
explosion
and ever since we've been trying to
figure out what had Disturbed this
deadly carbon dioxide cache perhaps it
was a rockfall that mixed a water layers
it could have been a minor earthquake or
even a small volcanic eruption at the
bottom of the lake even though no
Tremors were reported by survivors
whatever happened a tremendous amount of
carbon dioxide was suddenly released
anywhere between 100
000 and 1.6 million tons according to
various estimates due to the inertia of
the explosion CO2 initially shot upwards
at 60 miles per hour at 9 pm on that
fateful day villagers heard a rumbling
noise and many emerged from their homes
to investigate they witnessed gas
gushing upwards forming a cloud reaching
up to 100 meters other survivors
described a white Mist escaping from the
lake but what goes up must come down
especially when it's carbon dioxide and
one and a half times denser than air
suddenly the cloud rushed back down to
the lake surface before billowing
outwards like dropping marbles on a pane
of glass within seconds the gas clouds
spewed from the confines of the lake
rushing down the valley in a wave that
was 50 meters high with frightening
speed
as it surged forward the carbon dioxide
forced air out of its path and as it
made its way through the villages almost
all the people in its way lost
Consciousness colorless and odorless
this silent and Invisible Killer claimed
human and animal lives alike its victims
collapsing before suffocating
the carbon dioxide was of a strong
enough concentration that it killed not
only the people of Lake nios but many of
those in the suburb Cam and Char
Villages up to 15 miles away in the
closest Village to the lake only four
escaped quickly enough to survive most
died in their sleep but even the
so-called lucky few were permanently
Afflicted with breathing problems skin
lesions and paralysis
they were other volcanic gases present
survivors recounted a smell of rotten
eggs a sure sign of sulfur dioxide but
it was the CO2 that proved most
pernicious
a Survivor recalled the scene the
following morning no Birdsong or the
buzz of insects only a deathly silence
people and animals lay where they'd
Fallen some survivors took more than a
day to awaken
unsurprisingly many who did Rouse
believed it was the end of the world
scientists from different nations were
mobilized but at first they were all
baffled there were numerous theories
going around perhaps it was a vicious
virus epidemic but that idea was swiftly
dismissed as it didn't quite fit the
most popular view was that a dormant
volcano had bubbled and spit poisonous
gases killing those around nios but the
true tale would only unfold in the
ensuing mumps and years even though a
similar tragedy had struck the shores of
nearby lake manoon two years before
where 37 had died but those deaths were
recorded as unexplained as the idea of a
limnic eruption wasn't yet fully
understood
but now the tragic toll of lost life at
Lake NEOS compelled authority to take
such events more seriously and
scientists toiled to uncover the course
one of their conclusions was that this
very same tragedy could strike again
so they devised a plan to prevent this
the team fastened the rudimentary device
to let the gas vent from the Lake's
lowest depths through lymphy tubes
initially the water needed to be pumped
up through the pipe but once operational
the outflow of gas from the ascending
water caused a self-sustaining effect
that continually Drew more water upwards
similar to siphoning petrol out of a car
not that I would know of course in 2001
the first pipe was installed in Lake
NEOS followed by two more a decade down
the line
by 2019 however it was evident that a
single pipe was enough to keep the
carbon dioxide in check and so that's
what remains to this day hopefully
keeping the residents forever safe from
giant explosive wet farts
thanks for watching
foreign